下跌的時候真的很害怕
覺得有變便宜但是又不敢接
上漲了又覺得現在標的剛講這麼多
我該怎麼辦
這邊就要來請教骨魚了
其實在下跌的時候
就是買東西的時候
但是每次我問你
你都不告訴我要不要買
沒有 我現在不用理你了
我用低檔自動頭
對 一個月
據說啦
真正有在使用的朋友
是可以扣到10次喔
在7月喔
一路減便宜
你現在反彈上來開心到不行
當然現在的話
我們台股很厲害啦
光是照遠市值的
就有21檔那麼多
嗯 其實呢
以前呢我只認識一個趙而已
是不是 叫做趙華
真的嗎 可是呢
在這一波台股上來之後的話呢
我認識了21個趙
哦 這不是我花心了哦
我還沒說你自己承認了啥
那我們來看一下
目前市場的一個現況
那目前台股因為呢
我們的市值一直在往上走
所以 MSCI 這一次的調整的話
那台股在各個指數上面
幾乎出現一個全面性的調整
那當然在裡面
這些很多的一個成分股
到目前為止他的表現非常的好
而且他上半年交出來的 EPS 的一個
相關的數據
事實上也是非常的一個諒言
所以我們來看一下
到目前為止台股除了有 MSCI 調升的一個題材
還有很多黨的一個趙源谷
逐漸出現在我們的市場當中
那這些的話都是很多的一個利多
對台股市場的一個加持
那亞克今天在創歷史新高
真的是很強
記憶體裡面的代表
對 那為什麼他會在創新高呢
因為他目前他傳出說
他是現在的滴滴是長假的主導者
而且他爆出來的價格
比華方店 甚至韓國的廠商
報的更高
但是重點是呢
人家也買單了
竟然人家買單你又漲價
你又是主導者
那當然我的股價創高
這是個理所當然的一個結局
那當然除了你說
你看到南亞克之外
還有幾檔公司
也是你在投資的路上
你會覺得很訝異的
怎麼會是他呢
不可思議
尤其是像川胡這間公司
其實以前我們在講川胡的時候
都會跟
比如說像新日新那些公司
放在一起看
一個在做導鬼
一個在看腳鏈
對 腳鏈還沒有發酵
導鬼的倒是先衝出去
那我們來看一下
那為什麼他這一次導鬼會衝出去呢
來 我們先看
他最新的一個毛利率
假的 87%
預計今年的EPS
有機會會來到300塊
好 但是說實話
300塊錢也不是只有他
他就已經變成萬元股了
當然就萬元股了
但他明年的話
上看到420
所以呢 也就是因為他的整個EPS
突破到300以上
才造成他今天的股價
一路往上去做一個飆升
那你覺得如果穿胡的話
那就錯了
我們的趙元谷
他有一檔很特殊的
富芳記
終於來了一檔
我們買得起的東西
對啊
南亞科都500了
穿胡都1萬2萬3了
對啊
來檔這個100多塊
但是你買得起
但是你可能會看錯
他的獲利能力
那我們怎麼講呢
事實上的富芳記
他是一檔趙元谷沒有錯
但是他的股價也默默的來到了一個三位數
其實以前超過100
大家都嫌貴了
我剛才第一個印象也是
做了一個100塊的話
不然有他120嗎
以前我們看到富邦金100
哇靠 怎麼那麼貴啊
對不對
可是現在你看前面看到500塊
1萬塊之後再來看100塊
好便宜哦
而且更重要的是哦
富邦金呢
他事實上他有一些字節的公告
你知道玄機藏在哪裡嗎
玄機就藏在金融業
不能夠說出的真相
什麼東西啦
金農業呢
他表面上跟你講
這是他最新的公告
1到6月
我的ETS是6.67元
怎麼樣
感覺上
不錯啊 行嗎
可以啦
可以好不好
OK啦
可是金農業
因為我們的金管會
有很多的限制
所以導致他有一些獲利
說不出口
這邊要小心講
我們的主管機關
對
然後他會跟你講說
我如果今天是用這種方式
來做我的EPS統計的話
也就是說我有些處分利益
我可以放到我的EPS
來看的話
我實際上1到6月賺的錢
不是6.67
是13.17
也就是說上半年
我的獲利的能力
已經超過一個股本了
那全年一看的話
哎呀 怕是人啊
這不就兩個股本以上
妥妥在線了嗎
好 但是我必須問你了
你在評估他的 EPS 和本益比的時候
你要用哪個版本
我們一定保守的跟你用這個版本嘛
對不對
但是呢 我如果真的要買的時候
我們會去評估他這個數字是不是真的
因為確實金融業呢
他在做處分利益的任列的時候
他是有一些限制的
因為之前他們做了一些選擇
所以導致現在的話
不能夠把獲利放到檯面上
所以這個數字也是真的
也是真的就當作一個輔助
因為他沒有辦法放到檯面上
就不好評估
對 但是他有強調一件事情
這個EPS
他是可以拿來當現金鼓勵發放的
所以他的發放能力會很強
所以有些人就會把說
富邦金其實以目前的狀況來講
他可能是有低估的
但是我們講到這邊 造化
你有沒有覺得投資是一件很複雜的事情
長期覺得 不然
我們節目怎麼能天天做呢
你看做產業
產業不一定看得準
看這些財報數據
有一些真相又隱藏在很後面的地方
對啊
你如果沒有對他很熟悉的話
事實上你是抓不到
這個產業發展的tempo的
所以最簡單的方式是什麼
就用基金就解決了嘛
對不對
可能大家很流行就是
覺得ETF ETF
變成市場現學
他掛在台股市場上交易
基金一天一個價
可是基金的門檻真的最低
就是幾千塊錢就可以開始的事情
對 而且基金呢
他以目前來講的話
他有非常多擋了一個基金
他目前整體的報酬的話
比家權指數還要來得高
以家權指數來講
近一年他的報酬率有83
可是有超過接近150擋了一個基金
他的報酬已經來到了111.7%
是遠遠高於家權指數的
而且我們來看一下
我們在這邊的話
幫你分成單比投資跟定期定了
我們來看這些主動式的基金
跟家全指數的一個比較
你有沒有發現
其實台灣的這些主動式的基金
他的表現還蠻好的
不論你是做單比的
還是你是做定期定額的
你都有機會可以拿到更好的一個
績效表現
所以你如果今天想要拿到更多
那你應該要做一件事情
化被動為主動
去選擇這些比較基金的主動式基金
你就有機會在這
整個市場上升的這個趨勢裡面的話
得到更好的一個報酬
其實有段時間大家在網絡上有討論
不是很喜歡主動式的ETF嗎
後來就發現其實所謂的主動式基金
他們的報酬完全不輸
而且因為不用每天在那邊跟人家講
我買進賣出什麼
反而比較多了一層
我可以默默壓制滑水的功力
對 而且我們來看一下
在目前很熱門的這些基金
我都幫各位整理在這張表裡面了
從安聯三雄
好不好 到凱基 到統一 到元大 國泰
富蘭克林
我全部都幫你整理在這個地方
你只要看這張表
就可以看得出來
最下面這行是我們的家全指數
家全指數
其實今年也很厲害
八成的家全指數
但是你是要跟其他
這些優秀的基金放在一起
比的時候你就會發現
你如果滿足了八成
你就錯過了一百
這個就是我們在投資的過程中
你必須要去面對這個問題
所以我們在做投資
常常是要去思考說
我到底要怎麼做
我才能夠有機會
在相同的趨勢裡面
拿到更好的一個績效表現
我們上次有在討論
有的經理人很猛對不對
台股這波下沙
他是逆勢
沒有錯
一直加碼
我們的
我們就會害怕
對
然後就沒有人把我們的手按在那邊
叫你加這樣子
這時候我就跟你說
怎麼樣
系統的機制很重要
是
我們之前在介紹基富通的時候
他有一個非常棒的功能
叫做低檔自動頭
那這個低檔自動頭的話
他的出發條件是什麼
跟20日前的進責去做比較
如果達到跌幅
他就做加碼的一個動作
但是他有適用的類型
比如說
像股票型跟平衡型
這是比較適合的
然後他有很多個選項
可以讓你來做一個選擇
所以我們就可以來看
假設你把這個機制
放在安聯的臺灣科技
剛剛今年的第一名
或是放在很熱門的統一黑馬上面
也是前段班
那我們就可以來看一下
純粹的定期定額
或是蝶幅3%就加碼
蝶幅5%就加碼
那他最後得到的一個績效表現
到底他會長成什麼樣子
你有沒有發現
你如果純粹定期定額
哎好像也還不錯
也不錯啊
所以這次就不要停扣啊
可是如果你有在去做一些加碼的話
哦
你有機會可以拿到
多20%以上的一個績效
你看喔
你如果今天投資的金額
如果夠多夠大的話
這20%
嚇死人
這也是一筆非常大的一個錢
在這邊
其實我覺得他一個很重要的東西
就是次數
因為你有增加次數
所以你的本利盒
其實他的部位有效放大
對 沒有錯
那這也是我們在做所謂
低檔加碼的一個好處
你如果純粹的定期定額
你能夠扣到的次數
基本上是固定的
可是你有加了一個
低檔自動擴的功能的話
一旦市場有回檔
他就幫你連續做加碼的一個動作
讓你有機會可以賺到更多的錢
所以我這邊
幫各位舉一個例子
我以安聯台灣的科技基金為例
我們去看一下最近三年
假設我去設了一個低檔自動擴的功能
他到底在這三年裡面
哪些時間
他會開始幫你做加碼的一個動作
我們以
近期的一個回測來看
7月這邊讓你扣好扣滿
那還有一次給你扣好扣滿
是在什麼時候
在2025年年初的時候
也是給你扣好扣滿
關稅戰爆發的時候
對 所以你看
這兩個都是大家印象非常深刻
一個大幅度回檔的時間點
而我們透過回測的一個建議會發現
我如果有做設定
我在這個大家都不敢
有敢加碼的時候
我透過系統的一個機制
連續幫我扣
讓我的整體的績效的話
可以進一步在往上創造
提升的一個效果
所以這個就是呢
低兩自動扣
他在系統上面
幫各位達成了一個非常良好的效果
因為同仁有設定嘛
對不對
3%可能扣3千 5%就扣5千
他扣後來就真的要補錢了
可以扣到10次以上
對 但是呢他現在很後悔
他應該把帳戶的錢補滿才對
沒有 他看起來蠻開心的
對 因為畢竟
那個有賺到這一波的一個帳子
所以我們來幫各位介紹一下
就是說我如果今天投資主動式的基金
有幾個原則是你一定要注意的
首先第一個
你一定要堅持定期定額的去買基金
這個基本盤一定要堅持
不要隨便去做停扣的一個動作
然後第二個的話
你想要增加你的一個績效表現的話
像這種
基富通的低檔自動扣這種功能的話
你一定要做
一定要把它設定進去
因為它等同是自動幫你做
逢低加碼的一個動作
那第三個的話
你可能要去思考一下
在我投資的過程中
我要不要去做一個挺例的策略
挺例的策略的話
取決於你是做長期還是做破斷
你如果做長期投資的話
我只要有縫隙加碼
讓我的部位一直往上裏加就好
反正你也沒打算要跑
可是你如果是做破斷的
或者是說你喜歡
偶爾會要有一點點入袋的感覺
那就可以考慮說
比如說達到獲利目標的10到15%
我就賣掉一些賣掉一些
讓我的獲利真正進到口袋
然後你可以拿去划一下
這樣子的話才有激勵的效果嘛
對不對
就嘴上說長期
心理其實想先轉個波段
這是每個人都必然經歷過的一個過程
我覺得每個人都是在投資的過程中
慢慢地去摸索
會找到一個最適合你的一個道路
不過我們在這邊的話
要來幫各位再做一個提醒
因為事實上肌腹通
有點太過分了
又過分了是不是
每次來講幾乎從都覺得
已經夠過分了
對
還有更過分
因為他把他的通路又擴了更大
他其實這樣大家覺得很喜歡一點
就是他幾乎有很多的手續費
都幫大家省到最省了
對
他除了幫你省手續費之外
他現在還幫你把通路
不停不停的往外去擴大
那他現在又有新的一個動作了
是甚麼
他最新的動作是什麼嗎
他這次跟郵局來做了一個合作
滲透到郵局去了
你要知道郵局的用戶是非常廣泛的嘛
對不對
那他這一次的話
他就是可以讓你直接
在下載機庫通的APP之後
你點選開戶
他可以讓你直接去選擇說
你跟你郵局的帳戶
直接來做綁定
是
那這樣子的話
你郵局的帳戶裡面的錢
就可以
透過機庫通的APP
然後也可以來做基金相關的一個投資
而且在這一次比較特別的話
你如果完成郵局的綁定動作的話
他還有送你一個購物金
真的多少錢
這是郵局那一邊的話
會提供一個購物金
來鼓勵你透過郵局的帳號
還說一個長期投資的一個動作
至於這個錢是多少的話
你可以自己去看一下相關的內容
好不好
這是一個釣魚線就對了
吉布通又把通路擴增了
而且這次地藏自動擴有發揮
他的功效了
希望大家都開心喔
這邊謝謝股員
其實台股有所謂的
兆元市值的產業
這個也有利外資進來投資喔
因為以前都說台股是潛碟市場
規模都比較小
都中小企業
現在我們的結構慢慢的著狀了
而資金也會來再進一步的一駐
所以這裡面有很多好公司
有金融股
但是也有所謂的外援股
用基金幾千塊錢就可以投入
這個是第一個優勢
第二個優勢
如果在夏天的途中
您會害怕的話
低檔自動扣
會幫您設定
你要3% 5% 10%
都可以來扣
這一波就發揮很好的效果
那最重要的是
現在又多加了一個郵局通路
也可以開戶到郵局來進行
這個網路上面買賣基金的相關手續
所以下載一下
基付通的APP
您就能瞭解所有的事情了
那這邊還是要提醒
購買基金購買ETF
都是有賺有賠有風險的
身購前一定要相約
公開說明書
好 今天非常謝謝三位的朋友
來到現場
猜古抬到了46000點
這波的反彈看似很急
不過有點算是羽絡均沾
大小古都有做反彈的情況
還瞎帶著非常好的財報力多
所以我們不妨在現階段
把重心回到好的基本面宣古上面
也希望今天的理財展開秀
對您投資有幫助喔
明天再會了 拜拜